how's it going Rose might ask Tommy
we're gonna keep playing some South Park
so let's do some extra question at all
let's see if we can actually take a [ __ ]
that would be amazing so hard okay I'm
pooping oh that's not good
holy [ __ ] what a great poop Oh Haley no
all right enough already let's do this I
quest I think I want to do the
manbearpig one so let's do that one
reach an ideal spot under South Park to
use the defibrillator I know where to go
let's go down here
wonderful all right what do we got here
yes so this is where I took stop for me
last time because I didn't have the
alien probe so now we can go here and I
already looted I because I'm awesome
alright so now we can go down here in
the sewers - you said defibrillator on
the cache - manbearpig but how do you
think we're doing gosh it's like you
don't pay attention alright this looks
new
cuz Oh Jeff South Park Jeff screams okay
yes okay all right
I'm glad I can talk
God somebody [ __ ] once literally was
this point that he wasn't in their main
story but that's good that they come to
complain come whatever I can't [ __ ]
English but let's do one quest at a time
okay
I don't [ __ ] you know it would be too
messy if I keep you're supposed to be
here somewhere
I didn't show this part I play these
long ago so but he's just here that's
that's all you need to know yes
hey nice work I will let you know of any
updates on manbearpig sure to share the
news on facebook i'm super-cereal nate
out from amber peg I'll contact you on
my internet when I pinpoint his exact
location
Oh [ __ ] idiot that's it alright well
let's at least we have the [ __ ] poop
quest so I said this before but
basically the house that's what I got to
say my name from like and mr. towel
Harold he's like
you count has the same moist towel and
mr hankey Towelie well no [ __ ] learning
ah that's how it's done baby that's what
I said sorry
I wonder why how do I get you down
there's got to be some remote control
I mean remote whatever alright let's go
here could be here you never know these
days there we go
remote control I don't know what they
call the puzzle out
I can go here oh cool now you see that I
don't want to touch that little [ __ ] all
right
I bet the other one is this on the other
[ __ ] side is a [ __ ] nugget fantastic
but I got one of those oh [ __ ] what's a
heart what are you staring at
yeah I do Oh goddamn I'll just kill them
really quick and that's how it go
breaking stands it [ __ ] is that
homeless crams relooking okay that's
another side Chris I guess but that's
not something we love oh how does that
even work how do I get past the Cuban
yeah we go
I like this this seems like a trap but
let's go down anyway
goddammit okay so allegory is ready now
or [ __ ] me I'll go and wait no dude that
outdoor what in the hell
- I'm dressed up down in a sewer looking
for people kid Oh job blood oh my god
it's South Park not a goddamn horror
game this is what happens when I haven't
played horror her in a while man aren't
they dead yet son of a [ __ ] Oh elevator
oh it's so good
Cartman's ass is the best man four out
of seven well [ __ ] me I just want to
find his [ __ ] the kid okay I need an
Al Gore what the [ __ ] do you want
hey how's your day going
have you or any members of your family
been [ __ ] annoying I he's not one of
those people yeah
I don't like me actually all right well
we need to go back well Al Gore it for
[ __ ] sake oh god damn it
goddamn I hate you what's down here Oh
goddamn [ __ ] the show I've seen it all
now
[ __ ] sake yeah yeah why'd you call me
I call your hobo
O'Shea sorry ma'am
and that man just feel so cold waffling
nice name now I got it
who said that
unfriend my unfriend Al Gore he's so
annoying
foxy is gonna rhyme friend that [ __ ] so
what's up here exactly he has to be
another sewer like another Oh God
what the [ __ ] this is so complex oh okay
here we me [ __ ] I hate Al Gore more than
ever i'm super-cereal
some of these cuts to be done some of
the TV Awards down here oh they said I'm
getting hungry
good job that's a fun [ __ ] oboes god
damn oh well neither are you you [ __ ]
ass like a job for the grand wizard and
his trusty sidekick I am the Grand
Vizier
and Al Gore keeps messaging me oh okay
we never been here okay got it got it I
think he just tricked me he made up man
we're pigs to trick me to get him being
friend on facebook cuz I was [ __ ] like
that where the help all the crap people
if we heard about the crab people
yeah we must be really far down then try
people people
damn that's about Bieber Saurez yeah
what the [ __ ] is he talking about you
doing anything right now I mean if I'm
gonna walk around I'm like I better look
good what do we got over here huh [ __ ]
stain [ __ ] - Pope really Pitt I can't do
anything with us
maybe there's something new I need to
learn oh that's funny
where are we now what yeah but I don't
want to be here we can go here whenever
when here oh my god I hear something ah
please be here you're nuts
come on
now you did I've got bigger things to
deal with Simon he has a not honest
honest this is [ __ ] mr. hankey okay
oh ah son of a [ __ ] it's here it's here
hey there yes I like that expression
except against bosses of course and I
can't help you more than once per day
just like I can't help anyone who won't
help themselves with rehab okay cool
Pisa poo is someone in luck we're gonna
have to try that one
for sure let's get out of the sewers now
let's get unfriend that [ __ ] I got
new message what the [ __ ] does she want
I'll have to sell things I'm faithful
you believe that honey it's a public
post ever get I'm glad it's up because I
like it
Al Gore the [ __ ] girlfriend but why
haven't you liked any of my facebook
messages unless of course you're no
normal human kid it's you manbearpig
hi have you now let us fight to the
death is he a boss battle station now
let's see how you like sitting through a
whole presentation ano no oh God he got
card Ben thanks
you cannot escape the scientific
certainty of global climate change
yeah oh god I want to kill him oh you'll
have tiny crab nipples there what is he
gonna do Gore tastic what is this the
vice president that makes sense
that's all of you guys excelsior [ __ ]
oh damn 5,000 come on Chi devayne
this has been to the Suez but it works
I'm sure my guy goddammit I need a
pee-pee I need everything now oh that's
right [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is seriously I
love my Nick crime allegory secret room
key what the [ __ ] is in there super
cereal kit secret [ __ ]
I bet manbearpig isn't here that'd be
funny looks like he pees in that corner
over there for our super scary old man
bit that's got to be pretty good [ __ ]
man
alright it looks like we're out of time
for today but I hope you boys enjoy
watching I'm glad there's actually seems
to be a lot of content out for side
quests oh that's cool leave it like if
you're watching I'll see you in the next
one stay awesome breast lobby